Thor didn't see where he was going for
answers sometimes my teammates don't
tell me things it's kind of open Thor
would be the exception yeah give me time
we don't know what the Maximoff kid
showed him Earth's Mightiest Heroes
pulled us apart like cotton candy
seems like you walked away all right is
that a problem I don't trust a guy
without a dark side call me
old-fashioned well let's just say you
haven't seen it yet you know Ultron's
trying to tear us apart right well I
guess you'd know whether you tell us is
a bit of a question then oh now we're
doing research that would affect it that
would end the team isn't that the
mission isn't nothing why we fight so we
can end the fight so we get to go home
every time someone tries to win a war
before it starts innocent people die
every time I'm sorry mr. stark good
Clint said you weren't mine but our
tractor it doesn't seem to want to start
at all don't take from my pile
hello dear tell me everything
what heals you do me a favor try not to
bring it to life I miss partner your
little mix I get it Maria Hill called
you right was she ever not working for
artificial intelligence
you never even hesitated look it's been
a really long day like Eugene O'Neill
long so how's about we skip to the part
where you're useful look me in the eye
and tell me you're going to shut him
down you know the director of me I'm not
the director of anybody just an old man
okay it's very much about you and I'm
the man who killed the Avengers my son I
didn't tell the team how could I so I'm
all dead Nick felt it the whole world
too because me wasn't ready how'd he do
all I could maximov girl he's working
you Stark playing on your feet I wasn't
tricked I was shown wasn't a nightmare
was my legacy the end of the path I
started us on you come up with some
pretty impressive inventions Tony war
isn't one of them watch my friends dive
you think that'd be as bad as it gets
really nope wasn't the worst part the
worst part is that you didn't
you
you